algunas veces no es necesario tanta
presentación dígame una cosa están
listos para abrir el sobre que les llegó
desde en la mañana
ya me dijeron afuera que estaban súper
ansiosos de que queda banda que haya y
ahorita lo vamos a abrir les digo en qué
momento ténganlo a la mano que van antes
quiero hacerles una pregunta va a
parecer un juego de palabras pero en
verdad es una pregunta seria que quiero
hacerles díganme lo primero que se les
venga a la mente cuando escuchen la
pregunta listos
si el padre es médico el abuelo es
médico el bisabuelo fue médico que creen
ustedes que será el hijo
se imaginan están conscientes de lo duro
que puede ser para este hijo la
respuesta que acabamos de dar porque tal
vez él estaba pensando ser contador ser
comunicólogo futbolista músico pero
nosotros acabamos de meterlo en un molde
la vida está acostumbrada a meternos en
moldes y así como esto hay muchísimas
condicionantes porque si es mujer le
gusta el fútbol para que emprende si
ocho de cada diez empresas truenan no
pierdas tu tiempo vas a ser músico está
seguro te vas a morir de hambre el
dinero corrompe saca lo peor de las
personas es decir hay tantas cosas que
nos condicionan que lo que quiero
transmitirles el día de hoy espero que
llegue el mensaje lo siguiente la vida
nos tiene como pre programados hay un
caminito en el que todo el mundo debe de
entrar piénsenlo bien es algo así como
estudia trabaja crédito de auto cásate
crédito de casa hijos colegios tarjeta
de crédito paga deudas no es un caminito
así y todo el mundo está por ahí al
final a veces es jubilate y eso quizás
sería lo medianamente bueno de la
ecuación sin embargo a las nuevas
generaciones ya se los están quitando no
entiendo ni nunca entendido porque la
vida el género el área geográfica las
creencias la situación
a veces la familia nos quiere meter en
algunos moldes en donde evidentemente no
todos somos felices si quedas bien y si
no pues a la fuerza
desde muy pequeño fui como muy crítico
de cualquier cosa que parecía
condicionarme me llamaba mucho la
atención las cosas que hacían todo el
mundo y trataba de hacer cosas
diferentes voy a tratar de demostrar con
ustedes un molde que a lo mejor no nos
hemos dado cuenta le voy a pedir un
favor quien en este momento traiga un
reloj de mano o de pulsera puesto
levante su mano y déjela arriba por
favor quien traiga un reloj puesto en
este momento ok muy bien parece que
tenemos a mucha gente puntual en
coatzacoalcos ok
no se rían no no lo traen de adorno
estoy seguro a bien dejen la mano acá
arriba y ahora le voy a pedir lo
siguiente deje la mano arriba solamente
quien traiga su reloj en la muñeca
derecha
paso
ustedes creen que el reloj en la muñeca
derecha no daría la hora correcta
como este hay muchísimos muchísimos
casos que nos condicionan aunque sea no
lo crean cuando estaba joven me di
cuenta de esto y empecé a utilizar el
reloj en la muñeca derecha nunca faltó
el que me quería sacar del error ya ven
que existe de esto siempre andan por ahí
no están mal ahí no va siempre explicaba
me lo puse aquí deliberadamente me da la
hora exactamente igual que la tuya
después de mucha explicación tomé la
decisión de simplemente no usar un reloj
tengo más de 30 años que no me he puesto
un reloj
la razón no quiero sentirme adentro de
un molde para mí siempre fue muy
inquietante el que nos trataran de meter
en algunos moldes y de buena suerte hace
poquito se popularizó la teoría de las
inteligencias múltiples no sé si la han
escuchado pero las inteligencias
múltiples hablan acerca de que existen
distintos talentos y que no solo el que
es bueno en matemáticas es una persona
inteligente también el que es bueno para
los deportes para hablar con la gente
para dibujar este también es inteligente
el problema es que la sociedad ha creado
un molde de la inteligencia en donde
solamente entra el que es bueno para
hacer operaciones matemáticas
si un niño llega a casa con un 10 en
matemáticas los papás se sienten
orgullosos y hasta lo presumen pero si
el niño llega con un 10 en dibujo y un 5
en matemáticas entonces te tocó un hijo
burrito que dibuja bonito
esa es la razón por la que hay mucha
gente viviendo su vida sintiendo que no
son buenos para nada y la verdad es que
todos tenemos talento todos tenemos algo
el problema es que muchos han dejado que
se lo roben y el problema más grave es
que algunas veces quienes se los han
robado son los mismos padres
einstein tiene una frase que me llama la
atención y que quizá la han escuchado en
ese índice si juzgas a un pez por la
forma en que trepa a los árboles él
vivirá toda su vida sintiendo que es un
inútil
y eso es lo que creo que le pasa a mucha
gente en la vida hay gente que anda por
ahí sintiendo que son inútiles una vez
escuché que hay personas que mueren a
los 20 años a los 30 años y a los 40
años aunque son enterrados hasta los 80
años
cuando llegó el momento en que tenía que
tomar la decisión de que iba a estudiar
yo tenía clarísimo que lo que a mí me
gustaba era comunicar crear ideas y
poder hablar con la gente pero no me fui
por ahí estaba viviendo en el boom de la
tecnología todo el mundo hablaba de este
rollo de que quien estudiara sistemas
tendría grandes oportunidades y se iba a
ser millonario
evidentemente a mis 18 años yo no estaba
peleado con esa idea y me pareció
interesante la propuesta y aunque sabía
que debería irme por otro lado tomé la
decisión de estudiar ingeniería porque
me parecía que era la profesión correcta
para un hombre padre de familia un molde
y tomé la decisión que lo iba a estudiar
en sistemas porque todo el mundo decía
que iba a ser millonario y me gustaba la
idea
terminé la carrera y la terminé con
buenas calificaciones porque les aseguro
soy muy terco si alguien tiene duda de
esto puede consultarlo con mi esposa soy
muy terco y terminé con buenas
calificaciones la carrera encontré
trabajo muy rápido mi papá mi mamá
felices mis hermanos felices todo el
mundo estaba contento yo llevaba 15 días
en el trabajo y ahora la persona más
infeliz
no me gustaba lo que estaba haciendo
estaba enfrente de una computadora
programando porque había estudiado
desarrollo de sistemas ocho horas
delante de una computadora sin poder
hablar con ella no me contestaba es
decir tenía un problema grave no me
sentía bien pero que podía hacer el
camino había sido bastante largo yo ya
estaba ahí yo no podía regresar a mi
casa y decirle a mis papás pues no estoy
feliz voy a renunciar imagínense se
llegaba con eso me van a desheredar era
evidente que ya no iba a ser millonario
tenía tenía que estar buscando
alternativas
qué haces cuando estás en una situación
como esta saben yo estaba tan a disgusto
en ese trabajo que me reporté enfermo un
par de ocasiones cuando iban a asignar
proyectos yo no quería que me lo
asignarán a mí y no es algo en lo que me
sienta muy orgulloso pero creo que en
ese momento era como un mecanismo de
defensa
en ese momento entendí que el problema
no era el saloon es que le pesaba a todo
el mundo el problema es el trabajo que
elegiste
y haces cuando estás en una situación
como esa la mayoría de la gente termina
resignándose que no es lo mismo que
aceptar porque el que acepta sabe que
esto es lo que tiene en este momento
pero siempre está buscando la
posibilidad para salir de ahí el que se
resigna siente que debe de vivir infeliz
porque esa es la vida que le tocó vivir
notan la diferencia
se requiere de mucho valor para salir de
una situación como esa y de reconocer
que nadie puede descubrir nuevas tierras
si no está dispuesto a perder de vista
la orilla
voy a tratar de hacer una analogía con
ustedes ubican estos tapetes de foami
con la letra los números que utilizan
los niños bien
imaginemos lo siguiente que por las
características que tenemos
características físicas talentos donde
se inteligencias lo juntaron todo y
formamos la letra s llegamos a esta vida
con la forma de la letra s por lo que
somos y lo que tenemos y lo que sentimos
ahora imaginen que la vida la cultura la
familia las creencias tienen un molde ya
hecho de una x una r una c y una p ellos
quieren que entres ahí tú evidentemente
te reconoces que eres una s que no
puedes entrar ahí pero te quedas callado
y haces todo lo posible porque parece
que hay mucha gente que eso espera
es posible que alguien que llegó con
forma de un a efe entre en el molde de
una e pero siempre tendrá un área sin
cubrir
sin embargo alguien que llegó en forma
de una equis nunca podrá entrar en el
molde de una o por más bonito que esté
el molde si no es para ti no es para ti
el hecho de que veamos que alguien entra
con facilidad en el molde de una x es
porque ellos son una equis pero tú
siendo una s jamás te vas a sentir feliz
estando ahí adentro así es que viene una
primer moraleja de la plática reconoce
que es lo tuyo en que eres bueno que es
lo único y deja de compararte porque si
te vas a comparar compararte con la que
la persona que fuiste ayer asegúrate de
ser mejor que el día anterior todo lo
demás es energía perdida
voy a explicarles una historia y creo
que la historia ayudará todavía más a
tratar de transmitir el mensaje
imagínense esto todo
tenemos un destino en el cual podemos
llegar y sentirnos felices sentirnos
plenos existen muchos destinos en
algunos de estos destinos se viven y se
hacen cosas diferentes que la gente
disfruta hay reglas que se rigen en cada
uno de estos destinos para cada quien
para saber cuál es el destino al que
debe de llegar tú lo debes de sentir
para poder disfrutar incluso el viaje el
problema es que estamos tan ocupados en
el hacer que se nos ha olvidado sentir y
entonces cuando llega el momento en el
que tú tienes que decidir cuál es el
tren de tu vida estás tan perdido que te
da lo mismo ir angola quiera cuernavaca
y entonces llega a alguien que siempre
aparece y que te compra el ticket el
boleto del tren el problema es que
también decide el destino por ti
y te dice que el tren sale mañana a las
3 de la tarde y al día siguiente a las
250 estás parado en la estación pensando
que vas a subirte al tren de la gran
oportunidad de tu vida dan las 3 de la
tarde
te subes al tren equivocado en este tren
hay muchas cosas que se van a vivir
incluso hay paradas en dónde vas a ver
gente que hace cosas que a ti no te
gusta pero igual tienes que empezar las
hacer porque todo el mundo las hace
va a haber ocasiones en que te vas a
hacer el dormido porque no quieres
bajarte a esa estación para hacer eso
pero alguien te va a tocar el hombro y
despertarte porque no quiere que pierdas
la gran oportunidad de bajarte y
disfrutar durante todo el recorrido
tendrás que hablar con gente que no
piensa como tú no siente igual que tú ni
tiene las mismas ideas que tú pero tú
tienes que empezar a decir que piensas
como ellos porque si no se excluyen o te
hacen bullying
finalmente llegas al destino y empiezas
a vivir en ese destino un destino en
donde no querías estar pero si te gusta
no te gusta eso ya da lo mismo el camino
fue largo y ya estás ahí
mucha gente
decide resignarse a esta situación y no
tiene el valor de regresar a la estación
para tomar un tren con algún otro rumbo
y yo siempre he pensado que el dolor de
quedarnos en un lugar en donde no somos
felices es mucho más grande que el dolor
que podemos encontrar en hacer el
recorrido para encontrar nuestra pasión
voy a regresar al ejemplo que les conté
en donde les decía que no estaba muy
feliz en el trabajo lo recuerdan bien yo
creo que algunas veces lo que no quieres
hacer yo estaba claro en que no quería
seguir programando y hablando con la
computadora durante el resto de mi vida
eso lo tenía clarísimo entonces a veces
pienso que lo que no quieres te puede
llevar a descubrir grandes pasiones
la adversidad tiene el talento de
descubrir pasiones que durante la
comodidad hubieran permanecido ocultas
e hice yo
y se usó sabía que nadie me iba a dar
trabajo de algo que yo quería porque
había estudiado otra cosa así es que
dije si nadie me va a dar el trabajo yo
lo voy a inventar entonces hice uso de
mis habilidades para hablar convencer
platicar con la gente y convencí a dos
de cuatro del departamento de sistemas
que renunciaran junto conmigo para poner
un negocio
y lo hicieron lo más interesante de esto
es que como había sido mi idea pues yo
repartir las funciones uno era el
director de desarrollo otro el director
administrativo y yo era el director de
marketing ventas y servicio al cliente
relaciones públicas todo lo que a mí me
gustaba yo lo agarré
y es que ahí me di cuenta que yo podía
empezar a crear mi oportunidad de
trabajo aproveché para leer estudiar
asistir a conferencias hice muchas cosas
que sumarán información a lo que en ese
momento estaba tomando la decisión de
poderme empezar a dedicar
en este momento quiero decirles algunos
tips que quizá les pueden ayudar a
encontrar el camino en donde se pueden
sentir felices ken robinson en uno de
sus libros habla sobre cuando tú
encuentras o logras que tu talento se
cruce con algo que te apasiona entonces
puedes decir que estás viviendo en tu
elemento para vivir en tu elemento
algunos de los tips que les puedo dar
son los siguientes piensa en que
platicas cuando la gente empieza a
hablar sobre eso a ti te brillan los
ojos esas pláticas en donde podrías a
amanecer hablando sobre ese tema o
piensa que cosas cuando las haces te
cargan de energía ese es un sinónimo de
que te está apasionado algo y que hay un
talento una inteligencia por allá dentro
que te llama la atención hay algunas
cosas como estas que puedes hacer otras
recomendaciones piensa que te has
descubierto haciendo que pase el tiempo
volando y tú no te has dado cuenta que
pasó el tiempo
los talentos son a veces como los
recursos naturales están por debajo de
la superficie y tú tienes que aventar te
un viaje al interior para descubrirlos y
una vez que los descubres aventarte un
viaje al exterior para poderle decir a
la gente tengo un talento que te puede
ayudar a ti cuando logras hacer eso no
solo vives en tu elemento sino que
adicionalmente logras hacer que tu
pasión se convierta en tu profesión
quiero hacer una aclaración con ustedes
hay mucha gente que confunde lo que les
hace feliz con lo que les da placer
no es lo mismo jóvenes me han dicho es
que a mí me gusta mucho y se me pase el
tiempo volando jugando a los videojuegos
pues sí sí estas seis horas jugando
videojuegos evidentemente eres bueno si
nos pusiéramos todos aquí a tejer seis
horas en 30 días estaremos haciendo
bufandas bonitas pero si algo te genera
adicción no puede ser felicidad porque
la felicidad da tranquilidad
y si alguno de ustedes cree que la
felicidad dura poco piensen en cuánto
dura el placer cuando compran un par de
tenis nuevos
el negocio que emprendí duró solamente
dos años se unieron algunas cosas que
algún día les contaremos evidentemente
había tomado un tren que no me había
llevado a mi destino final pero me había
gustado el recorrido había encontrado
cosas que me llamaban la atención me di
cuenta que dar ese paso no me había
llevado al destino final pero me había
ayudado a salir de donde no quería estar
es el momento de abrir el sobre la tiene
por ahí muy bien
hablando por favor lo que van a
encontrar adentro me va a ayudar a hacer
las conclusiones que quiero hacer ok lo
tiene por ahí van abran lo
van a encontrar una bolsita que tiene
una letra imaginen lo siguiente por
favor imaginen que esa letra que les
tocó al azar es la letra que lo
representa con las características los
talentos las pasiones que ustedes tienen
ahora se van a dar cuenta que tienen dos
moldes en un molde la letra entra a la
perfección pero hay otro molde en donde
su letra no acomoda denle una pensada
como están viviendo el día de hoy se
sienten que realmente ajustan a la
perfección o se sienten que están en un
molde en donde no están felices les
asfixia el hecho de tener el molde que
no ajusta con su letra tal vez les ayude
a recordar lo duro que es estar en un
lugar en donde no encajan bien pero vale
la pena decirles que alguien en esta
sala tiene el molde que les corresponde
y a veces sólo es cuestión de preguntar
o de buscar regresemos vamos a regresar
a la letra que se ajusta perfectamente
en el molde para hacer las conclusiones
les desafío a que cuando lleguen a casa
o al trabajo pongan su molde y la letra
que ajusta perfectamente en lugares
separados solamente cuando se sientan
que están haciendo algo que realmente
les apasiona y les hace felices pongan
la letra en el molde porque eso les va a
ayudar a recordar varias cosas la
primera que el futuro no depende de su
presente su futuro depende de las
decisiones que empiecen a tomar el día
de hoy la segunda cosa es que nadie que
deja el alma buscando su pasión puede
ser un fracasado siempre va a ser
sinónimo de dignidad de talento y de
valor y finalmente tener la letra en el
molde correcto les va a ayudar a
recordar que nunca es tarde para hacer
lo que siempre estuvieron destinados a
hacer muchas gracias